madame la Présidente
la séance est reprise nous reprenons
l'examen de la mission aide extérieure
de l'État du projet de loi de financeces
pour 2024 dans la discussion des
articles nous sommes parvenus à
l'amendement 1311 sur les crédits de
cette mission et pour l'amendement 1311
je donne la parole à Madame
Olivier merci merci Madame madame la
Présidente alors cet amendement alors je
j'ai l'impression d' d'avoir le mauvais
13 11
pardon voilà c'est celui-ci pardon
excusez-moi euh donc je vais présenter
le 131 et puis directement le 1312 qui
est aussi l'amendement de de repli donc
en 2023
105,75000 million ont été voté en loi de
finance initiale pour l'accès des élèves
français au réseau d'enseignement
français à l'étranger dont 104,4
millions précisément sur les bourse en
réalité ce sont 98,1 millions qui
étaient disponibles après application de
la réserve de précaution et du surgel en
cours d'année budgétaire c'est à peine
la la dotation versée à l'AFE en 2017
les élus les parents d'élèves les
association à l'étranger n'ont cessé de
le répéter cette dotation était
insuffisante particulièrement dans un
contexte inflationniste et
économiquement dégradé je ne vous
l'apprends pas la nette hausse des
besoins sur les bourses scolaires qui
excédait plusieurs millions de plusieurs
millions la dotation a donc obligé le
gouvernement à débloquer des moyens
supplémentaires conséquents notamment le
relicat de la soute mais également le
dégel de la réserve de précaution et du
surgel ce sont des mesures très
exceptionnelles elles ont porté à 114
millions les ressources disponibles en
2023 sur le programme 151 en 2024 les
crédits consacrés aux bourses scolaires
des français du Réau de laafe s'élevait
à 118 millions d'euros alors oui il y a
une hausse mais c'est une hausse de
plutôt 4 millions si on la rapporte au
114 millions finalement accordé en cours
d'année budgétaire 4 millions alors même
que notre opérateur public sera
définitivement privé en 2024 de la soute
dont il disposait depuis plus de 10 ans
et qui lui permettait d'ajuster les
versements aux familles d'examiner les
recours gracieux ou d'atténuer les
variations liées au change ou les effets
de l'inflation en somme de palier
l'insuffisance de la dotation fa
conclure Madame euh c'est pour c'est
pour cela que nous déposons cet
amendement et puis l'amendement de repli
13 12 pour enfin augmenter les budgets
de la EFE et le budget de ces bourses de
nos bourses scolaires merci beaucoup en
discussion commune le 1243 madame conou
Moret avec le 1244 pareil euh ils sont
pas tout à fait pareils non mais comme
ils sont en discussion commune je vous
engage à VO très bien alors je vais
prendre les
deux
ok
prés voilà merci madame la présidente
madame les ministre je voudrais d'abord
rassurer nos nos collègues nous allons
en effet demander des crédits
supplémentaires non pas parce que nous
aimons dépenser l'argent public mais
pour répondre aux besoins réels que nous
avons identifiés alors ce qui est
présenter comme une augmentation de 13,6
million d'euros de crédit alloués aux
bourses scolaires mais en effet qu'un
tromlo c'est ce que j'ai euh euh déjà
tenté de de vous démontrer ce ce matin
en effet le budget présenté l'année
dernière sé en révélé d'emblé
insuffisant le ministère obtenit un
dégel de la réserve de l'ordre de 5 %
donc mise de côté pour faire face aux
aléas procéder à des redistribution
ainsi que l'utilisation du relica de la
soute donc en 2023 ce sont donc 113,3
millions d'euros qui ont été ouverts en
2024 déduction faite de la réserve
ceux-ci s'éléveront à 112,6 million
d'euros soit un total inférieur à la
année précédente donc les restrictions
budgétaires se répercuteront
mécaniquement sur les familles elles en
ont déjà fait les frais cette année
puisque la dernière commission nationale
des bourses apporté la contribution
progressive de solidarité de 2 à 7
points et que de nombreux établissements
se sont vu contraint d'augmenter une
nouvelle fois les frais de scolarité
donc comment espérons-nous atteindre
l'objectif de doublement du nombre
d'élèves fixés par le Président de la
République sans accompagner les familles
qui ne peuvent s'acquitter des frais
décollage donc en l'état dans un
contexte infl aiste mondial ce budget ne
permettra certainement pas de répondre à
tous les besoins cela risque de pousser
davantage les postes cossulaires à
s'autocensurer pour rester dans les
limites de l'enveloppe ce qui est
contraire à l'esprit même de notre
politique des aides à la scolarité et à
l'exigence de mixité sociale qui doit
continuer à prévaloir au sein de notre
réseau d'enseignement c'est pour ça que
nous demandons une revalorisation des
crédits à hauteur de 20 millions d'euros
alors ça c'est pour le premier et le
allez continuer madame sur le 124 bon
donc le deuxième amendement que je
propose donc enfin que nous proposons
vise à compenser à minima le rhaussement
de la contribution progressive de
solidarité que je viens de de mentionner
relevé de 2 à 7 % si cette hausse ne
concerne pas les familles dont les
qutité est à 100 % elle s'applique de
façon minorée à celle dont la qutité se
situe entre 80 et 99 % et en totalité à
celle dont la qutité est inférieur à 80
%. cette décision ampute de 2,5 million
d'euros l'enveloppe au bénéfice des
familles et entraîne une baisse des
qutités et ainsi une augmentation du
reste à charge difficilement supportable
pour les plus vulnérables cet ajustement
relève d'une logique à proscrire
puisqu'elle équivaut à taxer les
familles déjà en besoin de solidarité
pour financer l'accès au système solaire
scolaire français à l'étranger de
familles plus précaires encore pourtant
compte tenu de l'importance des besoins
et de l'insuffisance des crédits alloué
aux bourses scolaires il est très
probable que le taux de la CPS sera
maintenu à 7 % lors de la prochain aine
réunion de la commission quand celle-ci
aura lieu merci beaucoup madame conou
Mouret avis de la commission monsur le
rapporteur merci madame la Présidente
ces quatre amendements qui visent à
revaloriser l'enveloppe dédiée aux
bourses correspondent à une crainte bien
réelle face à l'inflation l'augmentation
des frais d'collage que rencontre notre
réseau d'enseignement à l'étranger mais
nous avons aussi constater que la les
crédits dédiés à cette enveloppe
augmentent dans le budget de 18 millions
d'euros pour atteindre un total de 118
millions d'euros sachant je le sais que
par ailleurs la soute a été totalement
épuisée la commission émet donc un avis
défavorable sur ces amendements quel que
soit leur montant et y compris le
dernier qui vise à compenser la hausse
de la contribution progressive de
solidarité parce que nous
qu'il y a dans l'enveloppe de 118
millions la possibilité de les compenser
mais si cette crainte est prématurée
exprimé par les amendements elle se
révélera peut-être malheureusement
exacte en cours d'année en fonction de
l'évolution des frais de scolarité et de
l'inflation et il nous semble que c'est
davantage dans un budget rectificatif
que pourrait être pris en compte cette
réalité si elle survenait monsieur le
rapporteur madame la ministre pour le
gouvernement merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les les sénateurs
le Gouvernement est défavorable à cet
amendement d'abord les ressources prévu
pour le programme 105 et et dans ces
amendements le privraé lui sont
absolument nécessaires et par ailleurs
nous avons une forte augmentation dans
le cadre du PLF 2024 pour les bourses
scolaires et je le disais ce matin aussi
pour les élèves en situation de handicap
favorable au 4 madame la ministre au 4
très bien monsieur chanrel pour
explication de vote oui très
rapidement ça a été très brillamment
exposé par par mes collègues Mathilde
Olivier hène Conway on a un souci en
fait le budget actuel que vous proposez
pour les bourses scolaires finalement
est l'équivalent de ce qui a été dépensé
au cours de cette année parce que
effectivement ça a été dit il y a eu le
le dégel et la soute a été utilisée
complètement ce qui fait que vous avez
été même amené vous-même à augmenter la
CPS de 2 à 7 % preuve en est que ça
n'est pas suffisant justement sinon vous
n'auriez pas eu à faire ça et nous ce
qu'on demande et on vous a écrit
d'ailleurs madame la ministre à ce sujet
nous les les quatre parlementaires de
gauche des Français de l'étranger vous
ont écrit pour qu'on mette en place un
groupe de travail spécifique sur le
sujet des bourses scolaires groupe de
travail qui serait composer bien
évidemment des représentants des
syndicats représentant aussi des parents
d'élèves les associations d'utilité
publique également et et et les él nos
élus des élus consulaires ou de
l'assemblée des des Français de
l'étranger pour pouvoir discuter et
mettre à plat ce sujet des bourses
scolaire parce que vous avez cette
ambition de doubler le nombre d'élèves
mais à partir du moment où vous ne
doublez pas l'argent public
mécaniquement en terme de mixité sociale
nous aurons en pourcentage moins de
boursiers dans nos établissements donc
c'est un vrai problème politique que
nous avons par rapport à ça c'est-à-dire
que votre objectif de doublement
d'élèves sans augmenter les bourses
scolaire automatiquement va diminuer le
nombre de de nos ressortissants euh qui
ont besoin de cette aide et c'est notre
modèle aussi finalement d'éducation sa
force à l'étranger c'est d'avoir la
possibilité de permettre à des personnes
les plus démuni d'accéder justement à à
nos établissements français et ça vous
justement vous allez malheureusement y
mettre potentiellement faim donc je
pense qu'il faut mettre ça sur la table
est-ce que vous pouvez justement vous
engager devant la représentation
nationale à mettre en place group de
travail que nous vous avons demandé
merci Monsieur
chanrel très bien je vais mettre au voix
ces amendements qui ont chacun un double
avis défavorable de la commission et du
gouvernement le 13 11 présenté par
Madame Olivier qui est pour qui est
contre qui s'abstient il n'est pas
adopté le 12 43 deux avis défavorables
qui est pour qui est contre qui
s'abstient il n'est pas adopté le 13 12
deux avis défavorables même vote même
vote et le 1244 4 même vote même vote
très bien chers collègues avant de
continuer je voulais vous dire que cette
mission s'arrêtera à 15h45
conformément à la aux conclusions de la
conférence des présidents ce qui veut
dire qu'il nous reste
41 amendement à examiner dans le temps
jusqu'à 15h45 donc je voilà je vous
tirez les conclusions vous-même le 1250
nous est présenté par Monsieur
chanrel
donc entre la la la crise de de la covid
et la crise de l'Ukraine la crise liée à
l'invasion de l'Ukraine sur les prix de
de l'énergie les coûts d'État successifs
aussi que nous avons au Sahel ça a
conduit de nombreuses familles à
repenser leur le leurs priorité et ça a
eu pour conséquence
justement une diminution finalement de
la mobilité internationale des étudiants
face à ces difficultés donc c'est un
amendement pour permettre à Campus
France justement d'avoir des moyens
supplémentaires pour mieux accueillir
les étudiants étrangers dans les
établissements d'enseignement
supérieur très bien avis la commission
madame Goulet oui madame la Présidente
euh pour ces augmentations la la
commission a émis un avis défavorable
conc considérant qu'il y avait déjà
suffisamment de de crédit très bien viis
de du gouvernement madame la ministre
avis défavorable madame la Présidente la
dotation inscrite paraît suffisante bien
je vais mettre au voix cet amendement
avec un double avis défavorable qui est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstient il
n'est pas adopté le 1249 madame conou
Mouret
oui madame la présidente madame la
ministre sur le soutien financier à
l'Agence pour l'enseignement français à
l'étranger à la Mission laïque française
de 20 millions d'euros cette dernière
doit reprendre à sa charge 6 millions
conformément à l'accord 4 cadre de 2021
hors le système de financement de la MLF
est sousension du fait de la conjoncture
économique inflationniste qui s'ajoute
aux difficultés structurel de certains
lycées notamment en Espagne et la crise
au Liban de fait la MLF atteint les
limites de ce qu'elle est en mesure de
supporter financièrement et comme l'a
rappelé ce matin Jean-Baptiste l mooine
nous avons été un certain nombre à
adresser un un courrier pour vous
sensibiliser sur cette question madame
la ministre et donc par cet amendement
je voudrais vous faire une proposition
avant de trouver une solution
pour sauver le deuxème opérateur de
l'enseignement français à l'étranger
après l'opérateur public cet amendement
propose donc d'abander 2 millions
d'euros les crédits alloués à la EFE
afin que celle-ci soit en capacité
d'augmenter à même hauteur son soutien à
la MLF donc on ne n'habille pas Paul en
déshabillant Jacques ou vice-va en
réalité madame la ministre ce réseau
aurait besoin d'un soutien beaucoup plus
important compte tenu de son déficit
d'exploitation qui s'élève aujourd'hui à
7 millions d'euros et même d'un
moratoire de 2 ans donc nous ne pouvons
pas nous permettre de perdre cet
opérateur historique de la diffusion de
l'enseignement et de la culture
française c'est pourquoi nous tirons
avec cet amendement laette la sonnette
d'alarme et nous appelons à voter cet
amendement merci beaucoup avis de la
commission monsieur le rapporteur merci
madame la Présidente sur cet amendement
nous demandons l'avis du gouvernement
parce que en effet la MLF rencontre des
difficultés il ne faudrait pas que la
majoration de 8 million d'euros euh pour
laefe serent à combler ses difficultés
et de manière euh euh également
peut-être un peu plus général nous
souhaiterions pouvoir être éclairé
précisément sur le soutien apporté au
Liban dans son ensemble soutien tout à
fait légitime mais que nous retrouvons
de manière budgétaire sur beaucoup de
lignes différentes sans en avoir une
lecture globale vous êtes sollicité
madame la
ministre madame la Présidente Mesdames
et Messieurs les Sénateurs le
Gouvernement est défavorable à cet
amendement il a évidemment faut-il de
dire bien conscience des difficultés
rencontrées par la MLF nous nous avons
organisé des réunions entre le ministère
la EFE et la MLF dont le rôle est en
effet important dans l'attente des
résultats de ces réunion le soutien
supplémentaire n'est pas envisagé de de
notre part très bien Madame eving
guerono galraabédian pour merci la
présidente madame la ministre cette
semaine Jean-Luc cruel le sénateur de
Côte d'Ivoire a rencontré le directeur
général de la MLF ainsi que son staff la
discussion s'est portée sur la situation
financière catastrophique de la MLF qui
au mois d'avril si une aine n'est pas
faite va se trouver en état de session
de paiement cela résulte à la fois de
l'accord cadre avec lafe qui dure
jusqu'en
2026 qui est devenu mal calibré et qui
ne correspond plus au contexte
économique inflationniste de la mauvaise
gestion de la fe de la MLF pardon et de
l'obligation de laamf de verser à la sur
son budget les contributions de ces
établissements partenaires car plus
aucun de ces ces établissements ne
versent sa participation les motifs sont
la baisse du nombre d'élèves qui sont
inscrits donc la baisse des recettes de
l'établissement donc des difficultés
pour payer les professeurs donc en
finalité une offre éducative beaucoup
moins intéressant et attractive c'est un
véritable cercle vicieux je voterai cet
aventement de mes collègues à
contre-cœur je dois le dire cet
engagement financier supplémentaire ou
cet appel au secours supplémentaire que
nous sommes contraint de voir consentir
pour sauver ce réseau don on ne sait pas
à ce jour s'il est suffisant et
seulement ponctuel doit impérativement
s'accompagner madame la ministre d'une
révision avant son terme de l'accord
cadre avec la EFE d'un audit de
l'association de la communication du
plan de redressement avec les
projections financières à court et moyen
terme ces éléments sont nécessaires pour
nous permettre d'apprécier si le modèle
MLF est toujours pertinent merci merci
monsieur chanrel je redis hein si vous
pouvez être un peu concis dans vos
interventions merci très concis parce
que Madame la la ministre vous nous
dites vous reconnaissez vous-même le
gouvernement reconnaît les difficultés
rencontré par
laamlf mais quelque part vous dites non
quand il s'agit de lui donner plus de
moyens parce que ces difficultés sont
financières il y a eu le cas du
déconventionnement à Madrid et à
Alicante et je peux vous dire puisque
j'ai eu les les derniers éléments et
c'est c'est c'est terrible parce que
c'est 100 c'est plus de 100 119 élèves
qui sont partis au cours de l'année
suite à ce projet de déconventionnement
parce que les parents d'élèves aussi
subissent le contrecût le contrecût
c'est l'augmentation des frais de
scolarité le contrecout pour eux il le
voit bien c'est un un désengagement de
l'État la force de notre réseau c'est
justement parce que la France est
derrière c'est ça qui fait sa réputation
si vous désengagez de ces établissements
automatiquement ça ça les met encore
plus en difficulté financière puisque
les familles qui les financent s'en vont
et partent donc il est urgent de pouvoir
justement financer adéquatement la MLF à
travers justement la proposition de de
de ma collègue hélenne Conway que vous
avez la possibilité de faire voter dès
aujourd'hui bien Monsieur jean-bste Le
Moine merci beaucoup madame la
Présidente je ne sais quel sera le sort
réservé par notre assemblée à
l'amendement ni le sort de l'amendement
le cas échéant dans la copie finale du
projet loi de finances pour 2024 après
qu'il retourne à l'Assemblée nationale
néanmoins ce que je retiens de positif
aujourd'hui dans cet hémicycle c'est que
les uns et les autres j'ai eu l'occasion
de le dire à la tribune tout à l'heure
d'autres orateurs sont exprimés à
l'instant sur l'amendement et la
ministre également c'est que nul ne
remet en cause le fait que un travail
est engagé et qu'un travail va se
poursuivre pour trouver des solutions
parce que que tout le monde partage ce
constat d'un rôle majeur de la MLF dans
l'enseignement français à étranger et
également des difficultés qui sont
rencontrées et je dois témoigner pour ma
part que sur le sujet du Liban l'État a
toujours été là lorsqu'il le fallait
pour soutenir ce réseau également et y
compris les établissements de la MLF sur
sur ces zonesl donc ce que je veux dire
madame la ministre c'est que voilà nous
puissions dans les toutes prochaines
semaines déboucher que nous puissions
déboucher sur des mesures de soutien
effectif qui permettent à la MLF de de
passer le cap et de rester cet opérateur
péren solide dont nous avons tant besoin
hors de
France très bien donc je vais mettre au
vote oui monsieur cadiic vraiment je
vous demande après je je mets au vote
hein cet amendement le prè merci merci
madame la Présidente oui oui parce que
faut quand même revenir un petit peu sur
le sujet 2 secondes parce que là j'ai
l'impression qu'il y a beaucoup de
pompiers peroman donc j'étais à
Casablanca là vendredi et il y a quoi à
Casablanca il y a une école de la MLF
qui s'appelle l'zui qui est en
concurrence et de quoi il parle leur
concurrence avec le GD justement qui
bénéficie de subvention nous sommes en
plein sur le problème c'est qu'on
concentre toute notre aide
principalement sur le zgd on fait une
concurrence déloyale aux établissements
type MLF et après on vient se on vient
se rendre compte que il y a un problème
et bien c'est ça le sujet et ça n'est
pas en prenant 2 millions d'euros sur la
subvention à la Croix Rouge
international pour les mettre soi-disant
à l' MLF qu'on va régler le problème
c'est simplement en revoyant la question
de la gouvernance comment ça fonctionne
ce modèle parce que justement ça ne
fonctionne plus merci très bien donc je
vais mettre au voix cette cet amendement
1249 avec un avis défavorable du
gouvernement qui j'imagine est suivi par
la commission est suivi par la
commission donc deux avis défavorables
qui est
pour qui est
contre qui s'abstient il n'est pas
adopté le 1237 madame conou
Mouret alors cet amendement madame la
présidente madame la ministre vise à
soutenir la Caisse des Français de
l'étranger seul seul organisme de
sécurité sociale dédié à nos
compatriotes et surtout seule protection
sociale accessible dans les pays en
dehors de l'Union européenne alors pour
accomplir sa mission de service public
la CFE ne peut compter que sur les
recettes provenant des contrats
d'adhésion car contrairement aux autres
caisses primaires d'assurance maladie
elle ne bénéficie ni de taxes affectées
ni d'une fraction de la contribution
sociale généralisée alors même que les
Français de l'étranger continuent à
participer par le biais de leur
assujétissement au diverses
contributions sociales au financement de
la protection sociale en France elle
enregistre aujourd'hui un déficit
important du fait de plusieurs facteurs
d'une part elle doit absorber une forte
inflation médicale qui a accru le
montant des prestations de 10 millions
d'euros entre 2017 et 2022 d'autre part
elle doit s'adapter à un changement de
profil de ses adhérents puisque les les
retraités j'ai trop vite représente
aujourd'hui 2 ti3 de sa clientèle enfin
elle doit supporter le coût des contrats
précédant la réforme de 2018 donc nous
appelons donc un réengagement fort de la
part de l'État à hauteur de 25 millions
d'euros pour préserver cette caisse
absolument vitale pour nos millions de
compatriotes résidents à l'étranger
merci av la
commission merci Madame la Présidente
c'est un avis défavorable parce que
comme le dit l'amendement il y a un
déséquilibre financier et un faible
engagement de l'État pour la Caisse des
Français de l'étranger néanmoins il ne
paraît pas raisonnable à la Commission
de multiplier par 65 la contribution de
l'État dans ce budget au détriment de
notre réseau diplomatique mais je pense
que c'est aussi un amendement
d'appel très bien avis du
gouvernement le gouvernement est est
défavorable le montant envisagé est en
effet démesuré et nous poursuivrons la
discussion sur les prochains amendements
très bien monsieur chanrel
rapidement pardon de vous oui mais comme
ça a été dit c'est la CFE a une
particularité c'est que c'est une une
caisse d'assurance pour bien en quelque
sorte mais avec une mission de service
public qu'est-ce que ça veut dire une
mission de service public c'est-à-dire
que elle et c'est tout à l'honneur de
notre pays cette caisse assure des
personnes qui ne seraient pas assurées
par les caisses privées pourquoi parce
que ça n'est pas rentable tout
simplement donc le à partir du moment il
y a une mission de service public ça
serait que l'État français puisse
financer cette caisse à la hauteur de ce
service public et les 25 millions ils
viennent pas de nulle part c'est
l'évaluation qui a été faite par la
caisse elle-même sur le coût que
représente justement cette mission de
service public on a fait des
propositions également lors du PLFSS sur
le fait que les Français établis hors de
France eux-mêmes payent de la CSG c'est
RDS vous prenez ne serait-ce que
0,01 % de la CSG c'est ce que nous
avions proposé ça fait ces 25 millions
d'euros donc en fait tout simplement si
vous avez la la possibilité de financer
cette t parce que elle est en grave
difficulté financière et c'est pas les
quelques miettes qui sont donné pour la
catégorieed catégorieed qui s'élève à 4
millions 4 millions et on donne 360000 €
donc sur ce sujet-là aussi on a fait une
proposition l'ensemble des
parlementaires des Français de
l'étranger de cet hémicycle ont écrit au
président du Sénat également pour que le
gouvernement organise un justement une
conférence de la protection sociale des
Assises de la protection sociale pour
qu'on puisse réellement parler de cet
enjeu pour pouvoir régler les
difficultés de de la Caisse des Français
de l'étranger très bien je vais mettre
au voix cet amendement avec deux avis
défavorable qui est pour qui est contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adopté
ensuite de amendement en discussion
commune le 1238 madame conou Mouret
oui madame la présidente madame la
ministre j'avais peu d'espoir de que le
précédent soit adopté donc nous avons un
amendement qui appelle à minima à
financer le reste à charge de la Caisse
des Français de l'étranger pour la
catégorie ed qui offre une tarification
spéciale à nos compatriotes les plus
démunis si le code de la sécurité
sociale prévoit que l'État apporte son
concours au financement de ce dispositif
spécifique dont le coût est estimé à 4
million d'euros pour la CFE la part de
de ce concours n'est pas fixé par les
texes ce qui lui a permis de réduire sa
participation d'année en année elle est
ainsi passée de 50 à 10 % aujourd'hui ce
qui a alourdi les dépenses de la caisse
et la fragilise l'État devrait prendre
pleinement sa part au financement de la
catégorie aidé qui relève de la
solidarité nationale c'est pourquoi nous
proposons d'abonder les crédits alloués
à la CFE à hauteur de 3 millions d'euros
pour combler cette différence merci le
1277 monsieur
Leleu merci madame la présidente madame
la ministre mes chers collègues
j'associe dans cet amendement les
rapporteurs pour avis de la commission
des affaires étrangères de la défense et
des forces armées du du Sénat des
programmes 105 et 151 Valérie Boyet
Jean-Baptiste Lemoine et Guillaume
Gontard par cette amendement nous
souhaitons doubler le concours de l'État
au financement de la catégorie dite aidé
des adhérents à la CFE la Caisse des
Français de l'étranger vous le savez la
CFE est un organisme de sécurité sociale
de droit privé à adhésion volontaire à
destination des Français résidentes à
l'étran cré en 2002 la catégorie
regroupe ceux de nos compatriotes qui
n'ont pas les ressources suffisantes
pour cotiser à cette caisse il bénéficie
d'une adhésion à taux réduit le
complément étant pris en charge
conjointement par la CFE elle-même et
par un concours de l'État l'article L
766-9 du code de la sécurité sociale
introduit en 2011 qui organise ce
cofinancement ne précise pas les parts
respectives de l'État et de la CFE de
fait le concours de l'État a très peu
évolué depuis cette date il est même
fixé à 380000 € depuis 2016 par une
convention à la CFE or dans le temps
dans le même temps les marges de
manœuvre financière de la CFE se sont
considérablement réduites en raison
d'une évolution dans la population des
adhérents les adhésions collectives via
l'employeur ont reculé tandis que les
adhésions individuelles notamment de
retraité suivaient le mouvement inverse
enfin le coût du dispositif a presque
doublé depuis 2011 pour atteindre 4
millions
d'euros le financement de la catégorie A
devrait pourtant relever de la
solidarité nationale
nous proposons donc un doublement du
concours de l'État les conséquences
financières seraient extrêmement
limitées outre la modestie des montants
l'État à ces dernières années abonder le
dispositif en gestion le concours en fin
d'année a ainsi atteint
964800 € en 2020 500000 € en 2021 et
764,800 en 2022 un abondement en loi de
finance initiale serait plus vertueux et
plus lisible pour la C CFE nous
proposons de relever cette somme sur le
programme
105le merci et je vous remercie voilà
merci beaucoup avis de la
commission oui madame la Présidente
alors ce sont deux amendements soumis à
discussion commune et qui visent tous
les deux les le financement de la Caisse
des Français de l'étranger dont on a
déjà parlé le premier propose une
augmentation multipliée par 10 celui de
Madame conou Moret le
1238 l'autre un un doublement sur le
premier amendement le 1238 la commission
a émis un avis défavorable et a mis un
avis de sagesse sur le
1277 madame la rapporteur avis du
gouvernement merci madame la Présidente
le gouvernement souhaite mener une
analyse qui aille au-delà du coup de la
catégorie aidé afin d'assurer la
pérennité de la caisse une mission de
Ligas pourrait ainsi être déligeantée
pour que l'on dispose de recommandations
et en attendant le Gouvernement s'en
remet à la sagesse de la Haute Assemblée
je dirais même à vite sagesse ce
bienveillant compte tenu du montant
raisonnable du
1277 avis défavorable sur le 1238 très
bien je vais mettre au voix ces
amendements le premier amendement 1238 à
deux avis défavorables qui est pour qui
est contre qui s'abstient il n'est pas
adopté le 1277 bénéficie d'un avis de
sagesse de la commission sagesse
bienveillante du gouvernement qui est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstient il
est adopté madame la ministre levez-vous
le
gage sur le 1277 levez-vous le gage le
gage il est levé très bien merci madame
la ministre le 1239 nous est présenté
par Monsieur
chanrel merci madame la Présidente en
fait cet amendement vise à reéhausser
l'enveloppe destinée à l'aide sociale
pour nos compatriotes établis hors de
France qui sont également bien
évidemment surtout pour les plus démunis
frappés de plein fouet par par
l'inflation dans le monde et aussi pour
comp penser la la variation des taux de
chance puisqu'il y a une une inflation
galopante dans certains pays notamment
par exemple l'Argentine où il est devenu
justement très difficile de pouvoir
accéder à cette aide sociale en raison
des des règles qui sont en vigueur
actuellement donc c'est pouvoir mieux
doter justement l'Aide Sociale à
destination de nos compatriotes à
l'étranger que vise cet amendement merci
Monsieur Gan l'avis de la
commission merci madame la Présidente
avis défavorable parce que nous estimons
que les crédits sont maintenus ils
avaient été augmentés dans le budget
2023 et que comme pour les boursse cela
doit pouvoir faire l'objet d'un
abondement en cours d'année dans un
budget rectificatif si la situation
sociale le nécessite du gouvernement
madame la ministre merci madame la
Présidente avis défavorable je note au
demeurant qu'en 2023 cette enveloppe
avait été légèrement
sous-consommé bien je mets au voix cet
amendement avec deux avis défavorables
qui est pour qui est contre qui
s'abstient il n'est pas adopté le 1307
nous est présenté par Madame
Olivier merci madame la Présidente la
France est le seul pays en Europe à
avoir mis en place un système d'A
sociale aussi bénéfique au profit de ses
ressortissants à l'étranger un
dispositif il est vrai qui ne repose pas
en droit inter interne sur aucune
obligation d'ordre législatif ou
réglementaire comme a a le rappelé
chaque année le ministère de l'EUR et
des Affaires étrangères ce qui n'empêche
pas de refuser la rupture d'égalité
entre les Français porteurs de Hang
qu'ils ai décidé de résider sur le
territoire national ou à l'étranger
aujourd'hui les conseils consulaires
pour la protection et l'aide sociale
considère irrecevables les demandes
d'allocation adultes handicapés de nos
compatriotes établis hors de France si
leur taux d'incapacité est compris entre
50 et 79 % alors que le code de la
sécurité sociale le permet en France
s'ils connaissent une restriction
substantielle et durable d'accès à un
emploi nous ne pouvons plus répondre à
nos ressortissants porteurs de handicap
à l'étranger que ces aides sont
attribués selon les moyens budgétaires
disponibles ou selon leur lieux de
résidence ce n'est pas notre modèle de
protection sociale la mise en place à
compté de janvier 2024 du principe de
décongjigalisation pour le calcul des
allocations adultes handicapé était une
décision remarquée et positive pourquoi
faire les choses à moitié continuons de
mieux prendre en compte le handicap de
nos ressortissants établis hors de
France plutôt que de créer deux
catégorie de Français en fonction du
lieu de résidence cet amendement
permettra l'affectation de 2 millions
afin de rendre possible un abaissement
du taux d'incapacité à 50 % au lieu de
80 % pour être éligiblebl aux aides
dispensées par les ccpas de la même
façon que nos compatriotes sur le
territoire national merci Madame Olivier
av de la
commission merci madame la Présidente
nous allons demander l'avis du
gouvernement parce que certes le système
enfin la hache ne peut pas être perçu
par nos compatriotes résidents à
l'étranger et sont elle est perçue par
les personnes vivants sur le territoire
national mais il y a eu un un choix de
s'aligner par les aides sociales du
ministère pour les personnes dans le
taux d'incapacité de plus de 80 % il
pourrait y avoir une logique à le faire
également pour celles qui ont un taux
d'incapacité entre 50 et 79 %. si vous
êtes sollicité pour votre avis madame la
ministre merci madame la Présidente pour
les mêmes raisons que pour l'amendement
précédent l'avis du Gouvernement sera
défavorable le taux d'incapacité retenu
pour les adultes handicapés à l'étranger
est fixé à 80 % pour les adultes 50 %
pour les enfants et le gouvernement a
choisi également d'étendre à compté de
janvier prochain le principe de
déconjugalisation ce qui permettra
d'élargir le nombre des bénéficiaires
très bien je vais mettre au voix cet
amendement avec deux avis défavorables
qui est pour qui est contre qui
s'abstient il n'est pas adopté le 1324
présenté par Madame Olivier monsieur
Mouli monsieur
mou
al c'est c'est donc créer un nouveau
programme afin d'accompagner nos
compatriotes résidents hors- de- France
dans la prise en charge de leur perte
d'autonomie en 2021 dans la foulée du
scandale Orpa était créée la branche
autonomie de la sécurité sociale dont la
vocation est non seulement d'organiser
des actions de prévention mais également
de financer des établissements
spécialisés de verser des aides
individuelles aux assurés en perte
d'autonomie ou en situation de handicap
or comme elle Commelle ne bénéficie
qu'au affiliés de la sécurité sociale
cette branche autonomie ne bénéficie pas
aux Français et français établis
étranger hormis quelques exceptions
spécifiques en effet en vertu du
principe de territorialité les
Françaises et Français établis à
l'étranger ne peuvent s'affiller à la
sécurité sociale hormis quelques
exceptions spécifiques c'est par exemple
le cas pour quand la personne touche une
retraite française ou quand la personne
est expatriée mais les expatriations
formelles sont de moins en moins
fréquentes c'est pourquoi nous proposons
d'élargir les prestations gérées par la
branche autonomie aux Français et
Français établis à l'étranger cet
élargir cet élargissement se traduirait
par la création d'un nouveau programme
dans la mission action extérieure de
l'État cela certes cela ne fait pas sens
pour une partie d'entre elles comme le
financement établissant spécifique ou
les sitiens à la recherche mais quand il
est grand temps mais il est grand temps
pardon de procéder à un élargissement
dans d'autres domaines notamment en
matière d'aide individuelle cela
permettrait aussi de lutter contre des
ruptures d'égalité frappant en matière
de ces aides même si certaines aides
existe déjà pour les Françaises et
Français établir hors de France elles
ont elles sont beaucoup plus restreintes
c'est le cas pour l'équivalent de la
ation adulte handicapé qui est versé à
l'étranger uniquement aux personnes qui
ont un handicap reconnu d'au moins 80 %
alors qu'elle peut être versé à partir
de 50 % en France nous devons aider les
Françaises et Français en situation de
handicap ou en perte d'autonomie
indépendamment de l'or R de résidence
c'est un principe d'égalité républicaine
merci Monsieur mou avis de la
commission merci madame la Présidente
àis défavorable de la commission parce
que cet amendement crée un nouveau
programme en anticipant les leçons qui
seront tirés de la mise en œuvre de la
branche autonomie de la sécurité sociale
il nous semble que la réforme de la
prise en charge des Français de
l'étranger en perte d'autonomie doit
faire l'objet d'une d'une réflexion plus
approfondie avant de créer un nouveau
programme et de l'abonder de 5 millions
d'euros merci avis de la avis du
gouvernement
pardon merci madame la Présidente l'avis
du Gouvernement est défavorable je
rappelle qu'aucun pays ne fait autant
pour ses ressortissants à l'étranger et
par ailleurs j'ajoute qu'une aide
spécifique a duré déterminée peut-être
prévu pour des cas lorsque des personnes
âgées en maison de retraite ont des
frais de pension qui excèderaiit le
montant de leur
allocation bien donc je mets au voix cet
amendement avec deux avis défavorables
qui est pour qui est contre qui
s'abstient il n'est pas adopté le 1308
madame
Olivier merci madame la Présidente
l'action des oless est primordiale dans
le dispositif de soutien aux Français à
l'étranger nos partenaires interviennent
en relais de l'action des cons cu-là
dans des situations souvent difficiles
qui par leur urgenence ou leur nature ne
peuvent trouver de solution dans le
cadre des aides sociales classiques et
permettent d'assister nos compatriotes
dans les moments difficiles de leur vie
à l'étranger les violences sexistes et
sexuelles que peuvent subir nos
ressortissant très souvent nos
ressortissantes sont tout aussi
intolérables en français en France qu'à
l'étranger elles peuvent d'ailleurs
affecter d'autant plus profondément nos
compatriotes établis hors de France ou
de passage que ces victimes sont isolées
ou loin de le le proches et de leur
cercle familial nous avons un devoir
d'agir nous leur devons une meilleure
prise en charge à l'étranger en
complément des aides éventuelles dans la
continuité de l'action déjà engagée par
l'État les organismes et associations
animé par des bénévoles uvrant
spécifiquement à la prévention et à la
lutte contre les violances sexistes et
sexuelles et formé à la prise en charge
de victimes doivent être davantage
valorisé et soutenu notamment dans le
cadre des subventions olè la prise en
charge de nos ressortissants
ressortissantes victimes de violence
sexiste sexuelle ne représente toutefois
qu'une faible minorité des projets
subventionnés et des actions mises en
œuvre alors que le tissu associatif
existe donc pour répondre à nos propres
engagements auprès des Françaises et
Français à l'étranger tout autant que
sur le territoire national il est
proposé d'augmenter de 300000 € la ligne
budgétaire dédié aux oles en 2024 merci
Madame Olivier VI de la
commission les organismes locaux
d'entraide et de solidarité voi leur
dotation reconduite à l'identique par
rapport à l'an dernier par rapport à
cette année il y a un taux d'exécution
loin de 100 % n précédente donc il ne
nous semble pas nécessaire d'abonder les
crédits mais d'abord de les utiliser
pleinement donc demande de retrait sinon
avis défavorable très bien Madame la
Ministre avis défavorable du
gouvernement madame la Présidente bien
vous retirez madame Olivier non il est
maintenu donc je mets au voix cet
amendement avec deux avis défavorables
qui est pour qui est contre qui
s'abstient il n'est pas adopté trois
amendements qui font l'objet d'une
discussion commune madame Olivier je
vous propose de présenter le 1309 et
celui de repli qui est 1310 oui merci
madame la Présidente c'est ce que
j'avais prévu euh 163 ambassades 16
représentations permanentes 90 consulats
généraux 125 instituts français 832
Alliances françaises et et 540
établissements scolaires le parc
immobilier de l'État situé à l'étranger
représente une surface bâtie de plus de
2 millions de mètres carrés il est
valorisé à l'actif du de l'État pour 4,3
milliards d'euros la gestion d'un parc
immobilier aussi vaste est soumis à de
multiples règles de droit local est pour
le moins singulière c'est vrai mais elle
ne se fera pas sans stratégie
pluri-annuelle sans transparence sans
moyens adaptés et sans volonté l'État a
fait le choix de faire dépendre les
investissements nécessaires à la
transition énergétique du ministère aux
recettes provenant des cessations du
patrimoine français à l'étranger en 10
ans près de 200 emprises à l'étranger
ont été cédé pour un montant de près de
800 millions ur la vente de son propre
patrimoine a permis au Mme de financer
ses propres réformes maintenant que le
patrimoine s considérablement approvri
que les meilleures ventes ont été
réalisées que reste-t-il en 2024 les
crédits du compte d'affectation spéciale
augmente d'ailleurs pourtant la seule
opération majeure dont le financement
est attendu en 2024 est en
administration centrale le financement
du projet kedoret 21 pour l'étranger on
repassera pour répondre à nos propres
engagement et à l'urgence climatique la
politique immobilière à l'étranger est à
revoir de toute urgence or en 2024 le
PLF prévoit sur le programme 105
l'inscription de 68 millions en en AE et
59,9 millions de CP consacré à
l'entretien lourd à l'étranger la
dotation budgétaire annuelle du p105
doit être fixée à un niveau nettement
supérieur et correspondant au besoins
particulièrement en autorisation
d'engagement nous devons permettre au
MAE d'investir sur le long terme et
d'avoir une stratégie immobilière enfin
cohérente et adapté aux enjeux de ce
siècle d'où le fait de cet amendement
1309 et le 1310 demande aussi
l'adaptation des des locaux mais se
limite aux locaux du meae merci Madame
Olivier madame conou Mouret pour le
oui alors cet amendement vise à corriger
un double impensé budgétaire et
politique en effet ni le plan de relance
France 2030 doté de 4 milliards d'euros
pour la rénovation énergétique des
bâtiments publics implantés sur le
territoire national ni le fond vert doté
de 500 millions d'euros par le Président
de la République pour rénover plus de
40000 écoles en France n'a pris en
compte nos emprises à l'étranger
pourtant lors de mes déplacements je
constate que certains bâtiments même ce
construit récemment ne sont pas adaptés
aux aléas du climat c'est
particulièrement problématique pour nos
établissements scolaires où cela affecte
les conditions d'enseignement allant
jusqu'à l'interruption du fait de la
canicule des examens en jointin comme su
faut le cas en Tunisie donc à l'heure de
la COP 28 ne devrions-nous pas montrer
l'exemple dans le sillage du mouvement
que nous av nous avons initié avec la
COP 21 à Paris en rénovant l'ancien mais
aussi en incluant des critères de
développement durable utilisant les
énergies renouvelables dans les plan de
construction de tous nos bâtiments
français à l'étranger merci avis de la
commission sur ces trois
amendements merci madame la Présidente
avis défavorable de la commission parce
que nous tenons à rappeler que les
dépenses d'entretien lourd font déjà
l'objet d'une hausse dans le budget de
la mission et que donc nous sommes en
train de sortir de l'impensée budgétaire
dont parlait notre collègue Hélène
conoué Mouret que 15 millions d'euros
supplémentaires sont ouvert au titre des
dépenses d'entretien lourd en franceçis
à l'étranger et qu'une nouvelle dotation
de 4,8 million d'euros en autorisation
d'engagement est ouverte pour financer
la rénovation énergétique du parc
immobilier au du qu d'Orsa pas encore à
l'étranger mais nous estimons que c'est
un début que les crédits font aussi
l'objet d'une fréquente sous-exécution
donc avis défavorable à l'amendement
tenant compte d'un début de montée en
puissance de la part du gouvernement
merci monsieur le rapporteur madame la
ministre pour le gouvernement même avis
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs avis défavorable
du gouvernement d'abord l'augmentation
prévue est
conséquente plus
15,7 million d'euros qui permettra
justement de ne plus dépendre des
sessions et cette augmentation permettra
également de s'engager plus avant dans
le programme qui date de 2022 de
rénovation énergétique des bâtiments
merci Madame la min je je vais mettre au
voix ces trois amendements le premier le
1309 double avis défavorable qui est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstient il
n'est pas adopté le 1233 avec deux avis
défavorables même vote même vote il
n'est pas adopté le 1310 même vote même
vote il n'est pas adopté le 12003
amendements discussion commune le 1235
monsieur chantre
merci madame la Présidente cet
amendement en fait vise à doter
adéquatement notre administration
consulaire en terme d'emploi de création
d'emploi vous le gouvernement a pour
objectif de créer 700 ETP justement
d'ici la fin du quinquena et c'est une
bonne chose effectivement vous l'avez
dit vous-même madame la ministre on a
besoin de réarmer notre diplomatie et
effectivement c'est c'est ça va dans le
bon sens le problème c'est que au niveau
de notre diplomatie l'administration
consulaire est un peu le parent pauvre
de ces ETP puisque ça a été dit par
d'autres collègues ça serait un peu
moins d'une
dizaine pour cette année qui qui
pourrait de création de postes donc
alors que les évaluations qui qui sont
faites ça serait qu'il y aurait eu
besoin juste pour boucher les trous en
quelque sorte parce que les agents
consulaires sont souvent face à des
cadences infernales il y a des
surcharges de travail des burnout donc
c'est important justement de
correctement doter notre administration
consilière en terme d'emploi et cette
évaluation qui avait été faite par la
Direction des Ressources Humaines
justement du ministère et l'évaluer à
peu près à 300 ETP d'où la proposition
de cet amendement c'est de permettre un
fléchage beaucoup plus important de la
création de ces postes vers
l'administration consulaire des Français
de l'étranger merci Monsieur jeanrel
Madame conou Mouret s'il vous plaît pour
le 1236
oui c'est simplement bon ce qui vient
d'être développé par par mon collègue
bien sûr est partagé mais si
l'amendement précédent n'était pas
adopté cet amendement propose de
rétablir dès maintenant un maximum de
moyens humains dans les postes
consulaires afin de faire face à
l'urgence du traitement des retards
accumulés et d'anticiper l'augmentation
des dépenses des demandes merci beaucoup
madame madame Olivier il est défendu
défendu très bien avis de la commission
sur ces trois amendements oui madame la
Présidente la Commission a mis émis
trois avis défavorables il s'agit de
augmenter les les ETP ce qui a déjà été
fait dans le programme qui vous a été
présenté les amendements présentent tous
plusieurs difficultés la première est si
l'on considère que les auteurs
souhaitent que le gouvernement lève le
gage alors que l'amendement se traduit
par une augmentation nette de la masse
salariale ce à quoi la commission des
finances évidemment opposé à la au
regard de la forte dégradation des
comptes publics la seconde si l'on
considère au contraire que les auteurs
souhaitent opérer un redéploiement euh
cette opération de semble pas soutenable
à court terme pour le programme et que
de tels redéploiements ne pourraient pas
être opérés à l'aveugle ce qui ce qui
implique un minimum d'examen dans les
trois cas puisqu'il s'agit d'une
déclinaison de la même demande la
Commission a émis trois avis
défavorables merci Madame la rapporteur
madame la
ministre avis défavorable du
gouvernement madame la Présidente 165
ETP sont prévus cette année mais dans le
cadre d'un programme permettant
d'augmenter de 700 emplois d'ici 2027
les ressources humaines de ce ministère
cette année ce sont 30 ETP
supplémentaires qui seront créés dans
les consulats soit une part très
importante des 165 ETP nouveaux bien
donc je mets au voix ces amendements
avec deux avis défavorables 1235 qui est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstient il
n'est pas adopté le 1236 même vote même
vote et le 12 le 13 23 même vote même
vote ils ne sont pas adoptés amendement
1313 madame Olivier merci madame la
Présidente en 2024 la France accueille
les JO depuis plusieurs mois le meae se
mobilise pour la tenue de cet événement
il joue un rôle majeur en matière
consulaire afin de faciliter notamment
la délivrance des visas pour les
dizaines de milliers de membres des
délégations olympiques et paralympiques
l'organisation des j ne manquera pas de
générer une nouvelle hausse de la
demande partout dans le monde elle est
estimée à 440 visas par ETPT par les
services visas du ministère un rythme
difficile à soutenir pour les services
déjà en sous-e effectif chronique dans
le réseau et qui seront par ailleurs
déjà fortement mobilisés sur cette
période qui représente chaque année un
pic d'activité à cette occasion une
correction technique de plus 8 TPT
relative à l'allocation de moyens
humains temporaires supplémentaires dans
le cadre de la préparation des Jos et
Jeux paralympiques a par exemple été
mise en œuvre dans le p105 C peu au
regard des besoins des services nous
saluons par ailleurs la création du
Centre de soutien consulaire mais cette
structure assume déjà un rôle euh
important de soutien sur les activités
consulaires lors de près de 700 Mo mois
de mission au total par an ce qui est
considérable comme souvent lorsque se
tiennent des événements majeurs en
France le meae sera par conséquent
contraint de faire massivement appel à
ses agents déjà en poste pour des
missions de renfort temporaire ces
absences ne seront par pas pas pas sans
conséquence sur le bon fonctionnement
des services déjà en tension pour les
services visa l'administration
consulaire et les services centraux
particulièrement à cette période afin de
prendre toute la mesure de l'événement
que représente ente l'accueil des Jeux
Olympiques et paralympiqu nous invitons
le gouvernement à financer l'ouverture
de 30 postes temporaires en
administration centrale et dans le
réseau consulaire pour la délivrance de
visas et l'accompagnement des
délégations étrangères merci Madame
Olivier avis de la commission rapide oui
madame la Présidente comme pour les
autres amendements sur le même motif
même motif la commission a émis un avis
défavorable et retiré 2 million au
programme que vous visez semble pas non
plus une bonne idée puisque c'est ce que
vous avez refusé dans l'amendement de la
commission des finances merci merci
Madame la Ministre avis défavorable du
gouvernement nous nous sommes organisés
pour que le consulat olympique qui
ouvrira à partir de janvier fonctionne
bel et bien à partir de janvier très
bien donc je mets au voix cet amendement
avec deux avis défavorable qui est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient il n'est
pas adopté trois amendements qui font
l'objet d'une discussion commune je vous
signale juste qu'il nous reste 26
amendements et un quart d'heure 1245
monsieur chanrel et sinon c'est cette
nuit hein après l'autre maire donc voilà
donc oui le 30 juin 2020 notre Assemblée
a adopté à l' l'unanimité et la création
d'un fond d'urgence pour les les
Français de l'étranger et d'ailleurs cet
amendement est un amendement pour
permettre de doter le le un fond
d'urgence parce que nos nos compatriotes
sont en première ligne face au
dérèglement climatiqu et ces
conséquences les risques sanitaires ou
des évenements politiques majeurs donc
il faut donner les moyens nécessaires au
service de l'État pour interven venir
immédiatement auprès de nos compatriotes
en cas de situation d'urgence et en fait
ce fond d'urgence aurait vocation à
prendre en charge les frais de scolarité
les frais de protection sociale et les
coup Liers à la sécurité physique ou
sanitaire de nos compatriotes à
l'étranger merci le 1278 monsieur le
bleu oui merci madame la présidente
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
le 30 juin 2020 le Sénat a adopté à
l'unanimité une proposition de loi qui
vise à instituer un mécanisme d'urgence
pour les Français de l'étrang confrontés
à des catastrophes naturelles des
menaces sanitaires ou des événements
politiques majeurs pour reprendre les
travaux de la commission des finances
sur cette proposition de loi qui
considère que ce fond d'urgence je cite
renforcerait la sincérité des comptes de
la mission action extérieure de l'État
et que les crédits alloués à ce fond
pourrai être pour partie ouverts en loi
de finance initiale cet amendement vise
à créer un nouveau programme au sein de
la mission action extérieure de l'État
afin de doter ce nouveau programme fond
d'urgence pour les Français de
l'étranger victime de catastrophe
naturelles d'événements politiques
madeur de menace sanitair cet amendement
propose de prendre 5 millions d'euros
dans le programme 105 et plus
particulièrement sur l'action numéro 5
contributions internationales sachant
que les contributions de la France aux
organisations internationales ont été en
forte augmentation ces dernières années
la montée des tensions dans le monde
ainsi que la multiplication des
catastrophes naturelles du en partie au
réchauffement climatique sans parler des
menaces pandémique prouve la nécessité
de créer ce programme permettant de
financer l'aide d'urgence au français de
l'étranger se retrouvant en danger ou
leur rapatriment d'urgence je vous
remercie beaucoup et le 1328 madame
Olivier merci madame la Présidente
quatre cyclones pour la seule année 2023
le vanouatou dans le Pacifique Sud a été
frappé par quatre cyclones l'ambassade
de France s'est mobilisé et je tiens à
saluer les efforts faits par le
personnel sur place cependant le budget
disponible pour ces aides était limité à
5000 € seulement ce qui était largement
insuffisant si la situation actuelle est
déjà elle est encore amenée à s'aggraver
puisque le nombre de victimes des
catastrophes est malheureusement encore
amené à à croître à cause du dérèglement
climatique si au cours de la seule année
2022 185 millions de personnes ont été
directement affectées par des
catastrophes naturelles qui ont provoqué
la mort de plus de 30000 personnes ces
catastrophes deviendront toujours plus
fréquentes et vont toucher toujours plus
de personnes c'est pourquoi nous
demandons que le réseau consulaire
puisse bénéficier d'une augmentation
conséquente des moyens pour aider nos
ressortissants et ressortissantes qui
sont devenus victimes d'une catastrophe
à l'étranger merci beaucoup avis de la
commission merci madame la Présidente
donc le Sénat a voté il y a 3 ans pour
la proposition de loi qui établit un
fond d'urgence pour les Français de
l'étranger victime de catastrophe
naturel cette proposition de loi avait
d'ailleurs été approuvée par la
commission des finances en cohérence
avec ce vote nous donnons un avis
favorable au dernier amendement présenté
qui est d'un montant beaucoup plus
raisonnable qui commencerait à doter ce
fond de 100000 € et un avis défavorable
aux deux premiers voilà sur pour des
questions de montant nous donnons un
avis favorable au 3e merci monsieur le
rapporteur madame la ministre pour le
gouvernement merci madame la Présidente
avis défavorable de la part du
gouvernement il n'est pas nécessaire de
créer un nouveau fond alors que le
budget des aides sociales a été maintenu
d'une part et d'autre part la sécurité
physique de nos compatriotes est assurée
comme on l'a vu encore cette année grâce
au centre de crise et de soutien du
ministère et grâce à nos ambassades et
évidemment j'ajoute que en cas
d'événements majeurs particulièrement
grave nous procéderions collectivement
comme nous l'avons fait en 2020 en
prenant bien sûr nos responsabilités les
uns et des autres merci madame la
ministre je mets au voix ces amendement
le 1ier 1245 à deux avis défavorables
qui est pour qui est contre qui
s'abstient il n'est pas adopté le 1278
deux avis défavorables qui est pour qui
est contre qui s'abstient il n'est pas
adopté c'est le 1328 avis favorable de
la commission défavorable du
gouvernement qui est pour favorable de
gouvernement qui est pour qui est
contre il est
adopté le 1252 nous est présenté par
Monsieur
Chantrel le présent amendement en fait
il vise à augmenter la contribution de
l'office de secours de de et des travaux
de des Nations Unies pour les réfugiés
de Palestine dans le proche orient
en augmentant les fonds dédiés à
l'action 4 du programme
105 à hauteur de 10 millions d'euros
cette organisation à la porte des
services d'éducation de santé de secours
ainsi que des services sociaux elle gère
les infrastructures des camps et les
améliore elle propose des micro crédit
une assistance d'urgence notamment en
période de conflit et elle ne rend
compte de ses activités qu'à l'Assemblée
générale de l'ONU il revient donc à la
communauté internationale et donc à la
France également de permettre à cette
organisation en cohérence avec la ligne
défendue par notre pays d'apporter de
l'aide humanitaire aux habitants de Gaza
d'apporter une assistance d'urgence aux
réfugiés de Palestine c'est ce que cet
amendement
propose très bien VI de la commission
alors ce sera un retrait ou un avis
défavorable car
cette action dépend de la mission aide
publique au développement bien Madame la
ministreci merci madame la Présidente
c'est tout à fait exact tout ceci relève
du programme 209 par ailleurs la France
est déjà le 3è état contributeur à
l'unra et dans le cadre de la crise en
cours 100 millions d'euros je dis bien
100 millions d'euros supplémentaires ont
été annoncés dont 54 millions iront à
l'uner bien donc je mets au voix cet
amendement avec deux avis défavorables
qui est pour qui est contre qui
s'abstient il n'est pas adopté le 1246
nous est présenté par Madame con Mouret
oui madame la Présidente nous sommes
tous témoins que les populations civiles
sont malheureusement les premières
touchées dans les conflits armés qui se
multiplient dans le monde face au
déchaînement de cette violence il est
impératif de faire respecter le droit
international et notamment les règles
qui interdisent l'usage des armes
chimiques portées par cette organisation
nous proposons donc de revaloriser la
contribution française merci avis de la
commission merci madame la Présidente
l'avis de la commission est de demander
l'avis du gouvernement parce que la
France contribue à l'oiaac selon le le
montant déterminé par ses codes part de
l'ONU la France augmente par ailleurs
ses contributions volontaires cette
année aux organisations internationale
est-ce que le gouvernement estime qu'il
est opportun d'augmenter notre
contribution volontaire à la oiaac vu la
situation internationale donc avis du
gouvernement
demandz le Gouvernement est défavorable
madame la Présidente la contribution
obligatoire sera reconduite et à cette
contribution obligatoire s'ajoute le
versement chaque année de contribution
volontaire qui nous paraissent
suffisante merci je mets au voix cet
amendement avec deux avis défavorables
qui est pour qui est contre qui
s'abstient il n'est pas adopté le 1247
madame conou Mouret il est défendu avis
de la
commission la Commission demande le
retrait de cet amendement parce que la
France respecte l'objectif de
contribution fixée par le pue et c'est
au travers des crédits de la mission
action exérie de l'état de la mission
aide publique au développement la France
a fait de l'environnement une des
priorités thématiques de ses
contributions volontaires merci monsieur
le rapporteur madame la ministre avis
défavorable madame la
Présidente bien je mets au voix cet
amendement avec deux avis défavorable
qui est pour qui est contre qui
s'abstient il n'est pas adopté le 1242
monsieur chanrel il est défendu avis de
la commission c'est un avis c'est un
avis
défavorable forme à la LOLF et ne
présente pas de d'intérêt contte tenu de
la souplesse que nécessite l'Assemblée
des Français de l'Étranger très bien
Madame la
Ministre avis également défavorable
madame la Présidente merci je mets au
voix cet amendement avec deux avis
défavorables qui est pour qui est contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adopté le
1322 madame
Olivier il est défendu monsieur gontar
président gar très bien avis de la
commission
nous ne sommes pas convaincus de ce
l'internationalis de l'internalisation
dans un délai aussi restreint donc à
vite défavorable bien monsieur le
ministre pas défendu par des arguments
pas présentéson madame la ministre je
vous en prie
excusez-moi madame la Présidente le
Gouvernement est défavorable le vote
électronique a montré son efficacité
donc je pense qu'on peut rester en
l'état très bien donc je mets au voix
cet amendement avec deux avis
défavorables qui est pour qui est contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adopté le
1251 monsieur chanrel c'est c'est un
sujet majeur surtout en tant que
vice-président de la commission culture
c'est un sujet pour lequel je suis très
attaché c'est l'extension du passe
culture aux jeunes Français établis hors
de France qui n'y ont pas accès ça
permettrait justement ce passculture de
financer notamment les Alliances
françaises les instituts français les
librairies françaises cinémas français
qui n'ont bien besoin via ce Pass
Culture qui serait étendu justement pour
les Français établis hors de France très
bien avis de la commission merci
Monsieur chanrel de votre con il nous
semble que l'extension du passe culture
au Français de l'étranger coûterait
beaucoup plus cher nécessiterait une
évaluation donc avis défavorable très
bien Madame la Ministre pour le
gouvernement avis défavorable du
gouvernement les modalités d'extension
du passeculture au Français de
l'étranger font l'objet d'un examen
conjoint entre mes service et ceux du
ministère de la Culture en tout état de
cause nous sommes mobilisés pour que
notre réseau culturel permette le
meilleur accès de tous en particulier à
nos compatriotes à la culture française
merci Madame la Ministre donc je mets au
voix cet amendement avec deux avis
défavorable qui est pour qui est contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adopté le
1248 madame conou
Mouret oui depuis 2 ans les efforts
déployés en matière d'économie par
l'Institut français mérite aujourd'hui
que nous le soutenions en matière de
restructuration et et et donc pour ces
réformes en cours voilà c'est tout ce
que je voulais dire très bien mais
prenez le temps quand même madame la
rapporteur pour la commission cet effort
ne sera pas récompensé la Commission a
mis un avis défavorable très bien Madame
la Ministre pour le
gouvernement même avis de la part du
gouvernement madame la Présidente merci
beaucoup je mets au voix cet amendement
avec deux avis défavorables qui est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient il n'est
pas adopté le 13 15 madame Olivier merci
madame la Présidente nous séons par cet
amendement valoriser et soutenir les
acteurs et actrices engagés pour les
cultures alternatives il s'agit là de
l'ensemble de productions culturell et
artistiqu diffusé par des circuits
indépendants des circuits commerciaux
ordinaires la promotion par le réseau
culturel français permettrait justement
de valoriser à l'étranger la richesse
des propositions artistiques
contemporaines françaises et favoriser
la création et l'émergenence artistique
ce soutien peut revêtir différentes
formes au premier rang desquelles figure
le développement des rés id ou la
programmation d'artistes français ou
étrangers issus de cultur alternative
particulièrement dans le domaine des
musiques actuelles électroniques ou
urbaines représentative de la vitalité
de la création française et reconnue
partout à l'étranger C cet amendement
ambitionne que le financement du soutien
de la promotion et de la diffusion des
cultures alternatives par notre réseau
culturel puisse être relevé à hauteur de
600000 € en
2024 très bien avis de la
commission sur cet
amendement
excusez-moi madame le présidente on est
bien sur le 13 155 donc avis défavorable
puisque cet amendement vient abonder une
enveloppe déjà en forte augmentation
merci monsieur le rapporteur avis du
gouvernement avis également défavoraable
les besoins sont couverts dans le cadre
du projet de budget actuel qui augmente
fortement 50 millions d'euros
supplémentaires donc deux avis
défavorables qui est pour qui est contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas à adopté
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
nous arrivons presque au terme du temps
imparti pour l'examen de la mission
action extérieure de l'État il nous
reste 14 amendements à examiner au
regard du déroulement de la journée et
après consultation de la commission des
finances nous avons le droit d'aller
jusqu'à 16h10 au-delà conformément à
l'organisation de nos travaux décidés
par la Conférence des Présidents et en
accord avec la commission des finances
la suite de l'examen de cette mission
sera reporté à cette nuit à l'issue de
l'examen de la mission outreemère déjà
reportée donc voilà il a on a un petit
peu de de mou le 1240 madame conou
Mouret écoutez je pis pas parler plus
vite que tout à l'heure hein 10 mot bon
euh le dispositif de soutien aux tissus
associatif qui s'appelle le staff doté
de 2 millions d'euros à remplacer la
réserve parlementaire auparavant doté de
3 millions donc les crédits qui lui
seront alloués en 2024 seront stabilisés
sur la base de la non consommation les
les années précédentes pour deux raisons
principales les critères sont trop
restrictifs et donc dissuasifs pour les
associations et la commission nationale
outrepasse largement ses prérogatives en
rejetant la moitié des dossiers pourtant
validés par les Conseils consulaires
donc le nombre de demandeurs démotivés
d'essuyer des refus après être allé au
bout d'une procédure longue et exigeante
sur le terrain et donc en baisse et
pourtant je peux attester pour aller
régulièrement au contact des acteurs
associatifs lors de mes déplacement que
les besoins restent importants donc cet
amendement propose d'abonder les crédits
attribués au staff à hauteur de 1,6
million d'euros afin de retrouver
l'enveloppe des 3 millions d'euros merci
beaucoup avis de la
commission merci madame la Présidente
nous allons parler de la réserve
parlementaire la semaine prochaine lors
d'une proposition de loi donc demande de
retrait sinon avis défavorable madame la
ministre avis défavorable madame la
Présidente l'enveloppe en effet n'a pas
été consommée entièrement lors des trois
dernières campagnes très bien je mets au
voix cet amendement avec deux avis
défavorables qui est pour qui est contre
qui s'abstient ils ne sont pas il n'est
pas adopté deux amendements en
discussion commune le 1318 monsieur
méouli oui alors c'est majoré le budget
de l'aide universelle d'urgence pour les
personnes victimes de violence conjugale
afin de de garantir la disponibilité
d'une aide aux personnes qui en sont
devenu victimes à l'étranger les femmes
qui deviennent victimes de violence
conjugale rencontrent d'immenses
difficultés à échapper à l'emprise de
l'auteur des violences et à se mettre en
sécurité c'est un fait et ces
difficultés ont tendance à être encore
plus important dès lors que les victimes
résident à l'étranger nous nous aurons
l'occasion de développer ces difficulté
plus en détail tout à l'heure mais il
s'agit notamment de la mise en sécurité
du dépôt de plainte de l'accompagnement
toutes ces étapes si essentielles sont
plus compliquées à l'étranger soit à
cause d'une barrière de la langue soit
parce que les victimes de violence
conjugale sont guerre protégé dans le
pays de résidence c'est pourquoi ces
femmes résidentss hors de France ont
urgemment besoin de toute aide à
laquelle elle pourrait prétendre le
projet Doig de finance dont nous parlons
prévoit les crédits pour pour d'urgence
aux victimes de violence conjugale pr
créé par la loi du 23 février 2023
toutefois les crédits prévus risquent de
se révéler insuffisants pour répondre
aux besoins des victimes si on fait les
calculs chacune des 244000 victimes
enregistrées par les forces de l'ordre
ne pourrait prétendre à une a de 37 €
avec 37 € vous ne pouvez pas vous mettre
à l'abri quand vous devez loger quelques
nuits à l'hôtel parce que vous ne pouvez
pas revenir chez vous à cause de votre
conjoint violent alors que nous
demandons que l'État consacre au moins 1
milliard d'euros par an à la lutte
contre les violences sex et sexuel nous
appelons bien évidemment à une
augmentation de ce monton cette
augmentation doit être générale mais
elle doit aussi bénéficier aux femmes
victimes de violence conjugale qui habit
à l'étranger c'est pourquoi nous
proposons de majorer le montant prévu
pour l'aide d'urgence plus concrètement
on propose que le montant prévu par
femmes potentiellement victime de
violence soit également prévu pour les
Françaises résidants hors de France
merci beaucoup le 133 madame Renaud
garabédian merci madame la présidente
madame la ministre l'année dernière j'ai
déposé un amendement visant à créer une
aide spécifique pour permettre aux
femmes victimes de viandeolence
conjugale à l'étranger puissent rentrer
en France avec leurs enfant ceci
rejoignait la philosophie de l'aide
universelle qui a été créée
postérieurement pour les femmes qui
résidaient sur le territoire français
vous m'aviez opposé que des rapatriments
étaient organisés à la charge du
ministère lorsque la situation le
nécessitait après des vérifications que
j'ai effectué sur le terrain il m'a été
rapporté que le ministère prenait
effectivement en charge deux à trois cas
de femmes victimes de violence
conjugale qui étit prises dans les
différents pays alors qu'il y a environ
plus d'une centaine plus de plus de
centaine de cas de violence conjugale ma
question madame la ministre Ctait de
savoir est-ce que l'aide universelle que
vous avez créé peut servir aux femmes
françaises victimes des violences pour
les rapatriers de l'étranger en France
merci de votre réponse merci beaucoup
avis de la commission sur ces deux
amendements sur le premier amendement ce
sera sur le 1318 un avis du gouvernement
et sur le 1303 un avis défavorable très
bien av la du gouvernement l'avis du
Gouvernement est défavorable sur les
deux amendements la loi de février 2023
ne s'applique que sur le territoire
national métropolitain à ce jour et par
ailleurs nos consulats sont pleinement
mobilisés en soutien aux victimes c'est
ainsi que l'an dernier ils ont apporté
leur soutien à plus de
150 victimes de viol
donc je mets au voix ces amendements
avec deux avis défavorables le 1318 qui
est pour qui est contre qui s'abstient
il n'est pas adopté le
1303 même vote même vote il n'est pas
adopté ne perdons pas le rythme le 1325
nous est présenté par Madame
Olivier merci madame la
Présidente en décembre 2021 l'ambassade
de France à Singapour a lancé une
permanence à disignation des femmes
victimes de violence au sein de la
Communauté française grâce à cette
permanence les victimes peuvent non
seulement parler à des avocates et
avocats de droit français qui exercent à
Singapour mais elles peuvent également
contacter des avocates et avocats
Singapouriens cette excellente
initiative mériterait d'être consolidée
d'une part les avocates et avocats sont
aujourd'hui seulement bénévoles et ne
peuvent proposer la permanence que
pendant 4 heures par mois d'autre part
il s'agit d'une initiative isolée
puisque l'ambassade française à
Singapour a lancé cette permanence de
son plein gré en dehors d'un cadre fixe
sur les la lutte contre les violences et
surtout sans pouvoir bénéficier d'un
financement spécifique dès lors qu'il y
a une enveloppe dédiée nos postes
consulaires pourraient enfin proposer un
meilleur accompagn accompagnement des
victimes de violence de plus les postes
pourraient améliorer l'accompagnement de
nos ressortissantes et ressortissants
particulièrement vulnérables par exemple
les agents pourraient mieux conseillés
les personnes
LGBTQI plus à l'heure où l'homosexualité
demeure criminalisée dans 69 pays ces
personnes deviennent victimes de
discrimination de haine voire de
poursuit pénal dans certaines régions
enfin une telle enveloppe permettrait
d'améliorer les conseils que les postes
peuvent donner aux personnes qui
souhaitent avoir recours à d'autres
motifs au contraire et voilà je vaêre
là très bien merci Madame Olivier avis
de la commission la commission la
Commission a mis un avis défavorable
très bien avis du
gouvernement avis défavorable du
gouvernement ces formations sont déjà
prises en compte dans le programme de
formation du ministère très bien je mets
oui madame
billon pardon excusez-moi madame la
Présidente juste peut-être pour dire un
mot lorsque j'ai écouté tout à l'heure
les deux précédents amendements je
voulais juste dire que l'aide
universelle initié cette proposition loi
par notre collègue Valérie lard elle a
des elle elle demande des CAF donc à un
moment il faut éviter aussi de se dire
on va multiplier l'aide univ erselle
pour la mettre en application pour les
Français à l'étranger je vois pas
comment ça peut être mis en œuvre donc
euh évitons de de d'essayer de dupliquer
des des systèmes qui ne pourront pas
l'être dans ce cas-là par exemple donc
bien entendu il y a les consulats
peut-être qu'il serait intéressant qu'on
ait le des chiffres peut-être sur les
violences faites aux femmes et voir s'il
y a des consulats qui répondent mieux
que d'autres afin de prendre des bonnes
décision je vous remercie merci je mets
au voix l'amendement 1325 avec deux avis
défavorables qui est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient il n'est
pas adopté le 1327 madame
Olivier merci madame la Présidente alors
l'avortement est interdit dans pas moins
de 23 pays dans de nombreux autres
l'accès à l'IVG est limité à certains
cas spécifiques seulement à Malte par
exemple une IVG est seulement légale en
cas de danger pour la santé de la mer et
ce seulement depuis cet été avant
l'avortement y était complètement
interdit ailleurs l'accès à l'IVG
devient toujours plus compliqué comme
aux États-Unis l'Argentine risque de
suite vivre et l'accès à l'IVG peut être
difficile même dans les pays où l'accès
à l'IVG est de jurer garanti je pense
notamment à l'Italie où un grand nombre
de professionnels de santé continuent à
refuser de pratiquer une IVG laissant
des milliers de femmes dans un état de
détresse alors qu'une personne menstruer
sur 3 a univg au cours de sa vie nous
devons garantir le droit à l'avortement
l'État a l'obligation de garantir
l'accès à l'avortement en France mais
aussi à l'étranger aujourd'hui ce n'est
pas le moment pour parler du droit à
l'IVG dans la c'est le moment de parler
de du droit à l'IVG dans la Constitution
c'est le moment de garantir l'accès à
l'IVG à nos compatriotes établis hors de
France c'est pourquoi nous demandons que
l'État garantisse à nos compatriotes à
l'étranger l'accès à cette IVG vu que
cet accès peut être difficile voire
impossible il faut que l'État prenne en
charge le rapatriment pour une IVG c'est
pour cela que nous demandons 500000 €.
merci Madame Olivier avis de la
commission merci nous avons déjà débattu
de cet amendement l'an dernier c'est une
préoccupation de permettre à l'ensemble
des Françaises de pouvoir recourir à
l'IVG ou qu'elles vivent dans le monde
donc avis favorable à cet amendement
pour donner aux postes diplomatiques les
moyens de garantir ce droit très bien
vide de du
gouvernement merci madame la Présidente
avis défavorable du gouvernement qui
précise que les conditions de prise en
charge médicale en France de personnes
concernées sont à l'examen en ce moment
du ministère de la santé et de la
prévention très bien donc je mets au
voix cet amendement qui a reçu un avis
favorable de la commission défavorable
du gouvernement qui est pour son
adoption qui est contre qui s'abstient
il est adopté le
1326 monsieur président Gontard oui
merci madame la Présidente les victimes
de violence sexuelle doivent s'échapper
à l'emprise de l'agresseur avec avec
lequel ils habitent parfois elles
doivent avoir la possibilité de déposer
plainte et bénéficier d'un
accompagnement complet et immédiat tout
cela est extrêmement difficile quand
vous habitez en France c'est encore plus
difficile quand vous habitez à
l'étranger et ce pour de multiples
raisons pour commencer les victimes
connaissent souvent très peu de
personnes qui habitent à proximité mais
malgré ces barrières l'accpag
l'accompagnement des postes de consulaur
de demeure largement insuffisant nous
demandons que chaque poste consulaire
met au moins en place des informations à
destination des victimes en pratique le
poste pourrait ainsi expliquer à la
victime comment elle peut déposer
plainte auprès de la police locale et en
France où elle peut s'adresser pour la
sécurisation des preuves ou encore
quelle organisation propose un
hébargement d'urgence ou un
accompagnement de plus le poste pourrait
lancer des campagnes de communication
par exemple sur les modalités du dépôt
de plainte dans le pays de résidence
merci président avis de la commission la
somme est raisonnable la commission a
émis un avis favorable bien avis du
gouvernement avis défavorable du
gouvernement ce travail est déjà mené
par notre réseau consulaire même si bien
sûr tout travaill est perfectible je
crois que consula fond ce qu'il faut
très bien je vais donc mettre au voix
cet amendement qui a reçu un avis
favorable de la commission défavorable
du gouvernement qui est
pour qui est contre ah je vais avoir
besoin de compter alors donc je va vous
demander de refaire l'exercice qui est
pour 12 15 1
18 très bien qui est
contre 1 2 3 4 5
6 16 il est
adopté amendement 13 200 présenté par
Madame
Olivier merci madame la Présidente les
Françaises et Français qui habitent à
l'étranger mais qui veulent rentrer en
France rencontrent de nombreux obstacles
qui compliquent leur retour un des
principals obstacle constitue la
recherche d'un emploi en France le
constat est malheureusement très clair
l'agence qui est supposée euh succéder à
Pole emploi n'est guerre préparé pour
aider les Françaises et les Français
dans cette situation spécifique et qui
ont des spécificités qui sont multiples
ces derniers pourraient justement jouer
donc un rôle essentiel pour pour mettre
en valeur les expériences des Françaises
et des Français à l'étranger et les
aider dans leur recherche d'emploi quand
ils veulent venir s'installer en France
or les agents manquent d'une formation
spécifique et il n'y a pas d'information
qui pourrait centraliser les bonnes
pratiques ou les astuces c'est ce à quoi
nous voulons remédier la solution est
très simple nous demandons 500000 € pour
proposer des formations spécifiques et
la mise en place d'informations dédiées
merci Madame Olivier avis de la
commission la Commission demande le
retrait sinon un avis défavorable cet
amendement relève plutôt de la mission
travail et emploi plutôt que de la
mission action extérieure de l'État
madame la ministre pour le gouvernement
avis défavorable du gouvernement en
effet le conseil à la recherche d'emploi
en France pour les Français à l'étranger
ne relève pas des compétences des postes
diplomatiques et consulaires très bien
Madame vous le maintenez très bien bien
donc je le mets au voix avec deux avis
défavorables qui est pour qui est contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adopté le
1314 madame
Olivier merci madame la Présidente nous
souhaitons avant toute chose saluer la
baisse des émissions de gaz à effet de
serre lié au déplacement aérien depuis
l'administration centrale du ministère
entre 2017 et 2021 les efforts consentis
par l'administration depuis 2022 sont
importants le meae s'est d'ailleurs
attelé à construire et adopter son
propre plan de sobriété c'est une bonne
chose d'autant plus que les impératifs
liés à la mobilité des agents du MAE et
de la vie diplomatique induisent bien
sûr des solutions et un fonctionnement
adapté ce plan présente des mesures
ayant une application rapide qui sont
voué pour la plupart à durée pour
réduire les consommations d'énergie or
euh un projet de de de 248000 € de
compensation d'émission de CO2 lié au
déplacement aérien en 2020 avait été
identifié et passé en comité de
subvention en juillet 2022 ce comité l'a
cependant rejeté par sa nature hors
périmètre du comité et par sa forme la
direction des affaires financières du
MAE admet ne pas être en mesure de
lancer un marché public afin
d'identifier des mécanismes de
compensation comme d'autres ministères
par manque de temps et de moyens humains
il est urgent pourtant d'opérer des
changements de long terme nécessaires à
la neutralité carbone c'est pourquoi
nous invitons le gouvernement à décid
décideré de nouvelles orientations pour
les missions euh et à programmer la
publication d'un marché public dès 2024
avec le budget nécessaire afin de
mesurer les émissions de CO2 émises par
LE MEE et d'identifier les mécanismes de
compensation merci beaucoup madame
Olivier avis de la commission la
commission éimet un avis défavorable une
enveloppe conséquente a déjà été
consacrée par ce budget à cette question
et donc la Commission a mis un avis
défavorable même avis madame la ministre
merci madame la Présidente avis
défavorablees du gouvernement en
précisant que le train est désormais
systématiquement privilégié pour toutes
les destinations qui sont desservies par
le train les autres ce ne sera pas
possible pour les trajets de moins de 7
he ça concerne notamment bien sûr Nantes
pour mon ministère le Royaume-Uni le
Bénelux tous les conseils européens et
la Suisse par exemple il n'y a plus sauf
motif vraiment exceptionnel de
validation des demandes de déplacement
par avion pour ces destinations très
bien je mets au voix cet amendement avec
deux avis défavorables qui est pour qui
est contre qui s'abstient il n'est pas
adopté le
1321 merci monsieur le Président Gontard
merci merci Madame madame la Présidente
la loi de programmation du ministère de
la Justice pour la période de 2023 à
2026 permettra enfin de déposer des
recours contre une décision de refus de
légalisation de de documents mais cette
loi de programmation n'a pas permis de
rendre cette légalisation internationale
de documents plus accessible en effet
cette légalisation entraîne des coûts
non négligeables afin de mettre fin à
cette situation nous proposons donc de
créer une aide spécifique qui viserait à
couvrir les frais liés à la légalisation
internationale merci monsieur le
Président avis de la commission alors ce
sera un retrait ou un avis défavorable
la légalisation des documents étranger
ne forme pas une politique publique
définie au S au sens de l'article 7 de
la LOLF la création d'un tel programme
serait susceptible d'être sanctionné par
le Conseil constitutionnel donc nous
vous demandons soit un retrait ce sera
s'il y a pas de retrait ce sera un avis
défavorable très bien Madame la
Ministre avz également défavorable pour
les mêmes raisons très bien monsieur le
Président vous retirez le
l'amendement il est retiré très bien
merci mes chers collègues nous allons
procéder au vote des crédits de la
mission action extérieure de l'état
figurant à l'état B je n'ai été saisi
d'aucune demande d'explication de vote
avant l'expiration du délai limite je
vous rappelle que la commission des
finances est favorable à l'adoption des
crédits de cette mission je mets au voix
qui est pour qui est contre qui
s'abstient ils sont adoptés nous allons
procéder à l'examen des amendements pant
sont les objectifs et indicateurs de
performance de la mission action
extérieure de l'État figurant à l'état g
je suis saisie d'une d'une d'un
amendement 1274 qui n'est pas défendu le
100 329 madame
Olivier merci madame la Présidente cet
amendement a pour objectif d'indexer
l'indemnité des conseillers et
conseillères à la fe et des conseillers
consulaires sur l'inflation nous
demandons à ce que chaque année le
gouvernement rende des comptes en
expliquant si les indemnités ont été
revalorisées nous espérons bien entendu
que cette mesure de transparence incite
le gouvernement à revaloriser enfin
automatiquement les indemnités des
membres de laafe et celle des
conseillers et conseillères consulaires
sur l'inflation merci Madame Olivier euh
avis de la commission sur la création de
nouveaux indicateurs nous demandons
l'avis du Gouvernement très bien Madame
la Ministre euh l'avis du Gouvernement
est défavorable il y a pas besoin de
nouveaux indicateurs je complète ma
réponse en disant que la revalorisation
des indemnités des conseillers de France
des Fran à l'étranger est opérée
régulièrement sur la base de
l'augmentation du point d'indice de la
fonction publique avec une majoration
cumulée déjà de plus de 6 % très bien
euh donc deux avis défavorables puisque
la Commission avait demandé votre avis
euh je mets au vote au voit l'amendement
1329 deux avis défavorables qui est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient il n'est
pas adopté j'appelle en discussion
l'article et les amendements tendant à
insérer des articles additionnels qui
sont rattachés pour leur examen au
crédit de la mission action extérieure
de l'État je mets au voix l'article 50A
qui est pour son adoption qui est contre
qui s'abstient il est adopté après
l'article 50A nous avons un amendement
1234 qui nous est présenté par Monsieur
chanrel on va y
arriver alors c'est c'est c'est une
demande de de rapport madame la
Présidente ça vise à traduire justement
le les conclusions de la mission
d'information concernant le le Bapti
scolaire à l'épreuve de la transition
écologique qui a été conduite par par
notre assemblée et bien évidemment nos
établissements français à l'étranger
sont en première ligne en quelque sorte
face au réchauffement climatique par
exemple en Tunisie il y a même des
suspensions des cours en journée en
règle générale en raison de la hausse
des températures et c'est de permettre
justement un rapport que le gouvernement
nous nous fournirait pour pouvoir
identifier les pistes de solution de
financement notamment dans nos ogegd et
dans l'ensemble de notre réseau merci
avis de la
commission merci madame la Présidente il
y a un vrai une vraie problématique de
rénovation énergétique autant nous avons
donné un avis défavorable à l'amendement
de budgétaire tout à l'heure autant là
nous donnons un avis favorable car ce
rapport pourrait utilement accompagner
le rapport demandé par l'article 50A
profitez-en c'est rare pour les rapports
madame la
ministre le gouvernement donne un avis
défavorable en effet un rapport est bien
prévu par la loi du 28 février 2022 il
est en cours de finalisation et il
devrait pouvoir être remis au Parlement
dans des délais extrêmement brefs
désormais qu' est Satis fait en réalité
très bien donc je vais mettre vous
maintenez bien sûr monsieur chentrrel
donc je je je mets au voix cette
amendement avec un avis favorable de la
commission et un avis défavorable du
gouvernement car satisfait qui est pour
qui est
contre qui s'abstient il n'est pas
adopté le 1241 nous est présenté aussi
par Monsieur
chanrel c'est pas c'est c'est une
nouvelle demande de rapport concernant
le dispositif staff qui a remplacé la
réserve parlementaire pour les Français
de de l'étranger et qui est pas qui est
défaillant comme pour le système qui a
remplacé la réserve parlementaire
d'ailleurs en France et et donc c'est un
demande de rapport parce que il y a déjà
une diminution du budget c'était 3,2
million d'euros la réserve parlementaire
qui représentait les parlementaires
établi hors de France c'est passé à 2
millions et il y a aussi une
problématique c'est qu'on a une usine à
gaz technocratique qui a remplacé la
réserve parlementaire qui était pas
parfaite et au contraire je ne la
défends pas pour autant mais mais par
contre qui mériterait plus de souplesse
donc c'est pour ça que c'est une demande
de rapport pour avoir des pistes pour
pour permettre justement un dispositif
adéquat et qui prend en compte les
décisions prises localement par les
Conseils consulaires avis de la
commission avis de la commission
défavorable on revient à la
jurisprudence habituelle en matière de
rapport et nous renvoy au débat de jeudi
prochain sur la réserve parlementaire
bien Madame la Ministre avis défavorable
du gouvernement madame la Présidente un
groupe de travail sur les critères
d'éligibilité du dispositif ça existe et
il s'est réuni à plusieurs reprises une
annexe à ces conclusion doit définir
plus précisément les critères
d'éligibilité avec des exemples concrets
et se rajouter au document d'orientation
destiné aux associations merci Madame la
minist je mets au voix cet amendement
avec deux avis défavorables qui est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient il n'est
pas adopté le 1316 pour finir cette
mission nous est présenté par Madame
Olivier merci madame la Présidente c'est
aussi une demande de rapport cette
fois-ci sur le financement des instituts
français l'état du mescena comme
ressource financière dans le réseau
culturel français à l'étranger et le
montant des participations externes
mobilisé par le réseau culturel et de
coopération on se rend compte que les
financements externes des instituts
français sont sont vont croissants le
mess les participations versé sur les
comptes des établissements culturels à
l'étranger ne sont pas comp comptabilisé
en participation externes mais en
ressources propres à ce titre les
instituts français ont par exemple
généré près de 153 millions de recettes
propres en 2021 il convient donc
d'établir et c'est l'objet de cet
amendement un rapport sur les sources de
financement du réseau culturel français
à l'étranger et notamment des instituts
français merci Madame Olivier avis de la
commission avis défavorable sur cette
demande de rapport il nous semble que le
sujet pourrait davantage faire l'objet
d'un travail de contrôle de la
commission des finances notamment bien
av du
gouvernement avis défavorable du
gouvernement le misère est déjà à
disposition du Parlement les états
financiers consolidé de l'activité des
établissements autonomie financière dans
le cadre des documents budgétaires
annexés au projet de loi de règlement
merci je mets au voix C cet amendement
1316 avec deux avis défavorables qui est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstient il
n'est pas adopté mes chers collègues
l'ordre du jour va appeler l'examen des
crédits de la mission aide publique au
développement du compte spécial prêt à
des États étrangers pour le projet de
loi de finances de 2024 je vous propose
sans lever la séance une toute petite
pause le temps que nos rapporteurs voilà
puissent
switcher